dot voting or Zen voting allows you and
your team to zero in on the best ideas
this activity is actually a part of the
decide stage but it can follow the Crazy
Eights or any rapid sketching that you
do in Zen voting you lay out all the
sketches on a table or you tape them to
a wall then you give everyone a limited
number of sticker dots usually two or
three and you have people silently pick
the best ideas by placing their sticker
dot on that sketch it's important for
the voting to be silent so people can
choose without being easily persuaded by
the loudest person in the room after
voting you and your team can discuss the
best ideas take a minute to think about
your sketches and the example sketch
that was provided from the Crazy Eights
which to idea is to do like the best
after you made up your mind check this
box to continue